okay everyone let's get started
uh welcome back um to
uh theory of computation lecture number
six
um
so
we have been
um
looking at
a number of different models of
computation
and um
last lecture actually was an important
one for us because we
shifted gears um from our restricted
models um
finite automata and pushdown automata
and their associated
um
generative models regular expressions
and
context-free grammars
to turing machines which are going to be
the model that we're going to which is
the model that we're going to be
sticking with for the rest of the
semester because that's going to be our
model as we're going to argue today for
a general purpose computer
so in the sense everything we've been
doing up till now has or up until that
point has been kind of a warm up
but it's been um nevertheless has gotten
the chance for us to introduce some
important concepts
uh that are um used in practice and also
will serve as good examples for us
moving forward and also just to get our
you know
get kind of
um
uh you know in a sense on the same page
uh so
what we're going to be doing today is
looking at the turing machine model in a
little bit more depth
one can
define turing machines in all sorts of
different ways
but it's going to turn out not to matter
because all of those different ways are
going to be equivalent to one another
and so
we are going to
stick with the very simplest version the
one we've already defined namely this uh
the simple one tape turning machine
but um
we're going to
basically justify that by looking at
some of these other models and proving
equivalent so we can we'll look
at multi-tape turing machines
we'll look at non-deterministic turing
machines
and we'll look at another model which is
slightly different but it's still based
on turing machines called an enumerator
and we'll show that those all in the end
um
give you the same class of languages and
so in that sense they're all equivalent
to one another
and that's going to be served as a kind
of a
motivator um kind of to in a sense
recapitulate some of the history of the
subject
um and going to lead to our um
discussion of what's called the church
turing thesis so we will uh
i'll get to that in due course
and we'll also talk about uh some
notation for
um
languages and
notations for turing machines and for
encoding objects to feed into turing
machines as input but we'll get to that
shortly as well
uh
so let's move on then we will
next
go into uh
a little review of what we did with for
touring machines and um just want to
make sure we're all together on that the
very important concept for us this term
so the turing machine model looks like
there's going to be this finite control
there's a tape with a head that can read
and write on the tape can move in both
directions the tape is infinite to the
to one side and so on as i mentioned
last time
the output of the turing machine is
either going to be a halt
accepting or rejecting or loop that the
machine may run forever with three
possible outcomes for any particular
input the machine may accept that input
by entering queue accept may halt and
reject by entering q reject and it might
reject by looping which means it just
never gets to the accept state or the uh
it never gets to any holding state it
just goes forever but we still consider
that to be rejecting the input just
it's rejecting by looping
okay um
and as we defined last time a language
is touring recognizable as or as we
typically write t recognizable if it's
the language of some turing machine
the collection of accepted strings from
that turing machine again just as before
machine may accept
zero strings one string many strings but
it always has one language
the collection of all accepted strings
um
now if you have a decider which is a
machine that never loops which always
holds on every input
then we say its language is a decidable
language
so we'll say language is turning
decidable or simply decidable
if it's the language of some
decider which is a turing machine that
always holds on all inputs
so we have those two distinct notions
turning recognizable languages and
turing decidable languages
um
now as we're going to argue this
lecture turing machines are going to be
our model of a general general purpose
computer so that's the way we're going
to think of computers as touring
machines um
and
why turing machines why didn't we pick
something else
well the fact is it doesn't matter and
that's going to be the point of this
lecture
all reasonable models of general purpose
computation
um you know unrestricted um
computation in the sense of not limited
memory um are all
going to be are all
have been shown um all the models that
we've ever encountered have also been
shown to be equivalent to one another um
and so you you're free to pick anyone
you like
and so for this course we're going to
pick turing machines because they're
very simple to argue about
mathematically and also they have a
sort of a some element of familiarity
in that you know they're they they feel
like um you know you well they um
they're more familiar than some of the
other models that have been proposed
that are out there um you know such as
you know rewriting systems lambda
calculus and so on because turing
machines feel like a primitive kind of
computer and in that sense they have a
certain familiarity
okay um so let's start talking about
variations on the turing machine model
and we're going to argue that it doesn't
matter it doesn't make any difference um
and then whether this is going to be
kind of a precursor to a discussion of a
bit of the history of the subject that
we'll go and get to in the second half
of the lecture
so um
a multi-tape turing machine is a turing
machine as you might imagine that has
more than one well it has one or
possibly more tapes and so a single tape
turning machine would be a special
version of a multi-tape turing machine
that's okay
but you might have more than one tape um
as i've shown in this diagram
now uh
how do we actually use a multi-tape
turing machine well you present the in
and we're going to see these coming up
for convenience sometimes it's it's nice
to be working with multiple tapes so
we're going to see these later on in the
semester a couple of times as well but
for now um
you know we'll we're setting the model
up so that
the input is going to be presented on a
special input tape um so that's where
the input appears and it's going to be
followed by blanks just as we had before
and now we have these potentially other
tapes possibly other tapes which are we
call them work tapes where the machine
can
write other stuff as it wishes and those
tapes are going to be initially blank
so just all blanks on them
all of the tapes are going to be read
and write so you can write on the input
tape obviously you can read on from the
input tape and you can read and write on
the other tapes as well
um
so what we want to first establish that
by having these additional tapes
you don't get additional power for the
machine in the sense that you're not
going to have
you won't have additional
languages that you can recognize by
virtue of having these additional tapes
i mean you could imagine that having
more tapes will allow you to do more
things
you know for example if you have a push
down automaton
with two stacks
you can do more languages than you can
with one stack
so it's conceivable that by having more
tapes you can do more languages than you
could with one with one tape
but in fact that's not the case
what one tape is as good as having many
tapes uh and we're going to prove that
you know we're going to
quickly sketch through the proof of that
fact um
so uh the theorem is that turing machine
a language is touring recognizable and
when we say turing recognizable for now
we mean just with one tape um so
that's the way we've defined it so a
language is turing recognizable if and
only if some multi-tape turing machine
recognizes that language
okay so really that another way of
saying that is
if you have a language that you can do
with a single tape you can do it with a
multi-tape and vice versa
so one direction that is immediate
because a single tape turing machine is
already a multi-tape turing machine that
just happens to have one tape
uh so the forward direction of that is
is um
there's nothing to say
that's just immediately true
um
but if we want to prove the reverse then
we're gonna have to do some work
and the work is going to be showing how
do you convert a multi-tape turing
machine to a single tape turing machine
so if we have something that's
recognized by a multi-tape turing
machine it's still turing recognizable
what that means is you can do it with a
single tape turning machine so we have
to show how to do the conversion
and i'm kind of you know i'll i'll i'll
show you that i think in a convincing
way but we know without getting into too
much detail
so here is an image of a multi-tape
turing machine
in during the course of its input so it
has already we've already started it off
um you know initially it starts off with
the um other tapes the work tapes being
all blank but now it's processed for a
while
and you know the head on the input tape
is now has moved off from its starting
position at the left end it's somewhere
in the middle it's written stuff on the
other
tapes and what we want to do is show how
to represent
that same information
on a single tape turing machine
in a way which allows the single tape
turing machine
to carry out
the steps of the multi-tape turing
machine but using only its single tape
by virtue of some kind of a data
structure which allows for the
simulation to cut to go
forward okay
so how is the simula the single tape
turning machine going to be simulating
going to be carrying out this the the
same effect
of having these multiple tapes on the
multi-tape turing machine
so here's a picture of the single tape
turning machine it just has one tape
by the way i should mention that all of
the tapes are infinite to the right um
in the multi-tape touring machine just
as we had for the single tape turning
machine
and now uh with this uh single tape
turning machine it's going to represent
the information that was on
that's present on these multiple tapes
but using only the single tape and the
way i'm choosing to do that is going to
be particularly simple
i'm going to just divide up so here i'm
saying it in words uh it's going to
simulate him by storing the contents of
the multi-tape
on the single tape in separate blocks
so i'm basically going to divide up the
single tape uh turing machines tape
into separate regions
where each one of those regions is going
to have the information that was on one
of the tapes
in the um multitape machine
so for example here is on the first tape
it's got aabba
well that's going to appear here in that
first block on the single tape turing
machine
okay
sort of seeing it float down to suggest
that it's coming from this multi-tape
turing machine but that's really been
developed by the simulation that the
single tape turning machine has
obviously the single tape turning
machine doesn't have any direct access
to the multi-tape machine but it's going
to be simulating
so
this is how we're showing the data is
being stored on the single tape machines
tape so in the second block it's going
to have the contents of the second uh
tape of the turing multi-tape machine
and the uh the final
um
uh region of the single
tapes this is the final block
so-called of the single tapes tape is
going to have single tape machines tape
it's going to have their the rest of the
um
the contents of the last
tape of of m
and then it's going to be followed by
the same infinitely many blanks that
each of these um
tapes
are going to have
following the portion that
they may have written during the course
of their computation
okay
so that's what the single tape turing
machine's tape is going to look like
during the course of its computation
it's going to have the informations
represented in these blocks
capturing all of the information that
the multi-tape turing machine has in a
perhaps somewhat less convenient way
because the multi-tape turing machine
you know we didn't really make this
explicit and in part because it doesn't
really matter we didn't say exactly how
the multi-tape turning machine operates
what i have in mind is that the
multi-tape turning machine
can read and move all of its heads
from all of its heads in one step
so in a single step of the multi-tape
machine it can it can obtain the
information that's underneath each of
its heads
feed that into its transition function
and then together with the state of the
multi-tape machine decide how to change
each of those locations and then how to
move each one of those heads
so it's kind of operating on all of the
tapes in parallel
okay so now uh how how does the actual
steps of the simulation of the single
tape you know
by the single tape um machine uh how
does it go
so first of all
besides
storing
the contents
of each of the tapes in in s's single
tape
there's some additional information that
it needs to record namely
um m
has
a head
for each one of its tapes
but s has just a single head
and each of m's heads could be in some
different location you know in this case
as i've shown it
on the first tape its head is in
location three on the second tape it's
in location two on the third tape it's a
location on the last tape is in location
one
uh
so where were we we were simulating
the multi-tape turing machine with the
single tape turing machine
and we had to keep track of where the
heads are
and so we're going to do that by writing
the locations on those blocks
okay so
we're going to have
a special
dot
as i've shown here to represent the
location of the head in that very first
block so the heads on the b i'm going to
dot the b and i'm going to do the same
thing
for the locations of the others
um heads
and how am i getting that effect well
we've had seen something like that
before where we just expand the tape
alphabet of s
to allow for
these dotted symbols as well as the uh
irregular symbols we also have expanded
it to include those delimiter markers
that separate the blocks from one one
another which i'm writing as a pound
sign um so we can just get that effect
simply by expanding the tape alphabet of
s
okay a few more details of s that are
just worth looking at just to make sure
we're kind of all understanding what's
happening
so for every time m takes one step
s has actually a lot of work to do
because one step of m it can move all of
those
read and move all of those heads all at
one shot
s has to scan
the entire tape
to see what those what's underneath
those in effect virtual heads which are
the locations of the dotted symbols it
has to see what's underneath each one of
those heads
to see how to update the transition you
know update its state to the next state
and then it has to scan again
to
change the location
change the contents of those of those
tape locations and also to move the head
left or right by moving the effectively
now moving the dot left or right so
that's pretty straightforward uh
uh
there's one
complication that can occur however um
which is that what happens if
um
on one of the tapes let's say
m
starts using writing more content
then you have room in that block
uh to store that information
you know so if the m like moves it has
one zero one suppose m you know after a
few steps moves his head into the
originally blank portion of the tape and
writes another symbol there we have to
put that symbol somewhere because we
have to record all that information and
the block is like full
so what do we do well in that case s
goes to like a little interrupt routine
and
uh
moves shifts all of the symbols um to
the right one place
to make open up
um a location here where it can write a
new symbol for
uh
carrying continuing the simulation
so with that in mind
uh
s can maintain the current contents of
each of m's tapes
and um let me just note that here shift
to add room is needed
and that's all that happens in this
during the course of the simulation okay
and if of course if
s
as it's simulating m
observes that m comes to an accept or
reject state
uh s should do the same
okay so that that's our description of
how the simulation of the the single
tape simulation of the multi-tape
machine works
right
okay let's turn to non-deterministic
machines
now
if you remember for fine art and i hope
you do for finite automata we had
equivalence between non-deterministic
and deterministic
um uh finite automata for pushdown
automata we did not have equivalence we
didn't prove that but we just stated it
as a fact there are certain languages
that you can do with non-deterministic
push-down automata which is the model we
typically hold as our standard so the
some things you can do with
non-deterministic push-down automata
that you cannot do with deterministic
push-down automatic um you really need
the non-determinism they're not not
equivalent
for turing machines
we're going to get the equivalents back
so we'll show that anything you can do
with a non-deterministic turing machine
in terms of language recognition you can
also do with a deterministic turing
machine so remember we kind of mentioned
this briefly last time
the
non-deterministic turing machine looks
exactly like a deterministic turing
machine except for the transition
function where we have this power set
which allows for
multiple different outcomes at a given
step instead of just a single outcome
that you would have in a deterministic
machine so we represent that with this
power set
here um
applied to the possibilities that um the
machine would have as the
next uh next step
okay
um so we're now going to prove a very
similar theorem that a is recognizable
by an ordinary
one tape turing machine that kind of
goes without saying so that's how we
defined it a is turning recognizable if
and only if some non-deterministic
turing machine recognizes that language
okay
um again remember we're using
non-determinism in the way we always do
namely that
a non-deterministic machine accepts if
there is some branch or some thread if
it's not a computation ends up at an
except
other branches might go forever or might
uh reject part with part of the way
through
but acceptance always overrules them if
any branch accepts that's how
non-determinism works for us
okay so now
the forward direction of this is again
just like before immediate because a
deterministic turing machine is a
special kind of not a deterministic
turing machine which never branches um
not deterministically on any of its
steps
so that forward direction is immediate
the backwards definition is where we're
going to have to do some work
converting our non-deterministic turing
machine to a deterministic machine and
we'll do so as follows we'll take a
non-deterministic turing machine
uh here's our picture and we're going to
now
um
imagine its computation in terms of a
tree
um
and uh so here is the non-deterministic
computation tree for n on some input w
so n for nondeterministic uh
here is the tree um somewhere down here
it might end up accepting and as i
mentioned that is going to be uh
defining the overall computation to be
accepting if there is some place here
that's accepting
and the only way it can be non-accepting
computation if there is no
except that occurs anywhere
and somehow if you're going to convert
this non-deterministic machine to a
deterministic machine
the deterministic machine is going to
have to get that same effect
though it only has determinant you know
it doesn't have the non-determinism so
how does it manage that
well it's really going to be carrying
out the simulation
you know
kind of as you would imagine doing it
yourself if you were told you had to
simulate a non-deterministic turing
machine
which is you're going to search that
tree of possibilities looking to see if
you find and accept if you do then you
accept if you if you don't well maybe
you'll go forever or maybe you'll manage
to search the entire tree and then you
will
say
no i accept uh no i reject um
okay so let's just see again what the
data structure of that deterministic
machine's tape is going to look like
um
so the way this simulation is going to
carry out and and you know you could
program this in a host of different ways
and in fact the textbook has a somewhat
different simulation but i think this
one here is
uh lends itself a little bit better um
and maybe it's a little simpler
for description um in this in this
setting uh
but there's lots of different ways of
improving these things so we're going to
m is going to simulate n
kind of a little bit similar to the
previous uh simulation it's going to
break the tape up into blocks
and it's going to now store in each
block
a different thread
at a particular point in time
of n's computation
so you imagine where
m is going to be simulating and
sort of
um
doing the same parallelism
but
doing the
getting the effect of the parallelism
not through the non-determinism but by
maintaining copies of each of the
threads
on its tape and then updating them
accordingly
so the idea is i think not not too
complicated um
so let's just see some of the some of
the details here so here here populating
those blocks with the contents of um
ends tape on different threads at a so
you know maybe that corresponds to um
ends tape you know after the fifth step
of n
um you know on each of those threads you
have these three possibilities let's say
written down as three different blocks
um now uh
remember in the case of the multi-tape
simulation we needed to record some
extra information
extra information in particular we had
to record the location of the heads
by using those dotted symbols we're
going to do that again because each one
of these threads might have their head
in some different location but we're
going to have to do more
but actually so let's do one other one
thing at a time we're going to store the
head location
here they are all written down
as dotted symbols
but now there's something that goes
further because in a multi-tape case
there was one global state
that the multitape machine was in of
course at any given time it's just one
has one finite control it's in one state
um
and
uh but but but in the case of the
non-deterministic machine that we're
simulating now
each thread can be in a different state
um
so whereas before we could keep track of
the multitapes during
the multi-tape machine state inside the
single tape machines finite control
now there could be many many different
states to keep track of
so you won't be able to store that in a
finite control anymore because there
could be some huge number of threads
active at any given stage and some of
them can be one state others can be in
different state and you know how do you
keep track of all that so we're going to
have to use the tape
we're going to actually write down which
state a given thread is in on that block
and we'll do that i'll show it like this
so writing down the state of each cert
in the block
by writing down symbols which correspond
to those uh states
so we're actually in a sense writing the
states down right on top of block using
symbols that correspond to those states
so again we're doing getting that effect
by increasing the tape alphabet
of m
to include
um
symbols that correspond to each of its
states
i'm going to write those symbols down so
here's the symbol for state q8 that says
well one of th that very first thread of
n's computation is in state q8 it's in
this third position of its t um on its
tape uh the head is on the third
position there and the tape contents is
aaba
that's how we represent that thread of
the computation
um including the state
okay
now
um
so am is going to carry out that step by
step
maintaining that information on its tape
there again
similar to before there might be some
special situations arising so for
example n is not non-deterministic so a
thread might fork
into uh two threads
what do we do then um well sort of the
you know the reasonable thing if there's
a forking thread
m then copies that block
makes two copies of the block
to correspond to the two or however many
copies you need to correspond to the
possibilities that um that thread is
branching into so you want to represent
them all on different blocks of m's tape
all right um and then if m ever finds
out that on one of the threads it's
entering the accept state
it can just shut down the whole
computation at that point and say accept
okay so
perhaps a little elaborate but i think
conceptually hopefully
um
not too bad um
now uh
uh let's move on then to talk about uh
somewhat of a different uh
looking
well sort of a different model in a way
um
uh which has some historical
significance and sometimes it's a
helpful way to look at uh
touring recognizability and you and
incidentally you have a homework problem
uh
on this um model
called an enumerator or turing
enumerator
so
uh here
it's going to operate somewhat
differently
first of all we're going to enhance the
turing machine model it's going to have
just a single tape but it's going to
also have a printer
okay so we're now
adding in
this new device into the turing machine
called the printer
and um
the
turing machine has
tape as before except
we never provide any input to the
machine
the tape always starts out fully blank
it's only used for reading and writing
uh only used for for like the keeping tr
for uh for for work
uh it's not where you present the input
so how do you talk about the language of
the machine
well what the way you work this machine
is you take this enumerator
uh it's a deterministic determination
with a printer as i mentioned you start
it off in blank tape and it you know
runs and runs and runs and periodically
it can print
a string under some sort of program
control which i'm not going to spell out
for you but you can imagine you might
have to define the machine in such a way
that when it goes into a certain print
state so we're not going to set that all
up
then whatever string is in a certain
region of the tape maybe from this the
start point up into the head location
that gets printed out
on the printer
and then it can print out other strings
in due course and so
periodically you think of this printer
as printing out a string um
under the control of the uh
the turing machine enumerator
um
and so
these print strings these strings that
could print out w1 w2 they appear
and
the machine might possibly go forever
and print infinitely many strings
or it might
go forever and only print finally many
strings or it might stop after a while
by entering a holding state accepting or
rejecting is irrelevant but enters a
halting state and then
the number the strings that it's print
out the finite really many strings it
printed out are just that's the output
of the machine
now the language of the machine is the
collection of all strings that it ever
prints out
so we're defining language in a somewhat
different way here it's not the strings
that it accepts it's a string that it
prints
so we think of this machine almost a
little bit analogous to like the regular
expression or the grammar in the sense
that it's a generative model it produces
the language rather than accepts the
strings in the language
this is not really a recognizer it's a
generator and the language of the
machine as i'm writing over here for an
enumerator here we say that it's
language is the collection of strings
that it prints
okay
now we will show that a language is
touring recognizable in the previous
sense uh you know
recognized by some ordinary turing
machine
if and only if it's the language of
summer numerator
and actually this is kind of a little
bit of an interesting proof uh you have
to do some work it's an if and only if
now neither direction is immediate
you're gonna have to do some work uh in
both directions one direction is a
little harder and the other will start
off with the easier direction let's say
we have an enumerator
i hope you hopefully you got this
concept of this turing machine which
periodically prints strings
when you've started it off on the empty
tape
um
uh so now what i'm going to construct
for you
is that turing machine
recognizer
defined from the enumerator so this
recognizer is going to be simulating the
enumerator
um so it's
basically the recognizer going to launch
the enumerator
it's going to start off simulating it
um
now if you want if it's convenient we we
can use several tapes we can use one
tape to simulate the recognizer and you
have other tapes available for
convenience if you want because we
already showed multi-tape and single
tape are equivalent so if you want to
think of m as having multiple types it's
not going to really be that important
relevant to my conversation um
but you're going to simulate e starting
on the blank input as you're supposed to
and then you're going to see whenever e
prints an x
you're going to see if x is the same as
the input to the recognizer
you you get the idea so we have a
recognizer it has an input string maybe
like
1 1 0 1.
and i want to know i want to accept that
string if it's one of the strings that
the enumerator e prints out
because that's what the recognizer do
it's supposed to accept all the strings
that the enumerator prints out so i got
this one one zero one what do i do i
launch i fire up that numerator i get it
going and i start watching the strings
it prints out
comparing them with my input string one
one zero one
if i ever see it print out a one one
zero one
great i i know i can accept because i
know it's in the enumerator's language
but if i compare and compare and compare
i never see
uh the enumerator ever printing out uh
my input string 1101
well i just keep simulating if e holds
well then i can hold and reject
if i've never seen that string coming
out as an output
if e doesn't hold well i'm just not
going to hold either i'm going to go
forever but then i'm going to be
rejecting my input by looping
okay so that's the proof
of converting
in this uh backward direction which is
the easier direction now let's look at
the forward direction which has a
certain wrinkle that in it that we're
going to have to get to
so now we're going to be building our
enumerator to simulate our recognizer
okay and the way we'll do that
is
the enumerator has to print out
all of the strings that the recognizer
would ever accept
so you kind of do the obvious thing
you're going to
take the numerator is going to start
simulating
the recognizer m on all possible strings
sort of you know one by one using doing
them in parallel taking turns you never
know you know we um maybe we didn't make
this so explicit but you don't have to
you know you can sort of time share
among several different possibilities
you run you know it's sort of like
having different blocks uh for the
machine diff you're gonna run
um
uh the enumerator is gonna run the
recognizer on uh
it's you know well let's just say it
does it sequentially runs it on the
empty string it runs it on the string
zero it runs it on the string one runs
it on the string zero zero these are all
the possible strings in sigma star you
you run the on all of them
and
whenever
the enumerator
uh
oh
this is wrong
whenever
um
so whenever
m accepts
then print
i can't
write very well
print
w
um
w i oops
okay
so let me just say it in words
you want to simulate emma on each wi
whenever you notice
m accepting wi you just print out w i
um
because you want to print out
all of the strings that m accepts
now what have the problem there is a
problem here so uh hopefully you're not
confused by this typo
um uh doing it sequentially like i just
described doesn't quite work so let me
just back that up here doing it
sequentially doesn't quite work
because emma might get stuck
looping on one of the wi's like you know
maybe when i feed w
zero into w
into m
m goes forever
because m is rejecting zero by looping
but maybe it also accepts one this next
string in the list the string one i'll
never get to one by just feeding the
strings into m one by one like this
what i really have to do is run all of
the strings in m in parallel
and the way i'm going to indicate that
is i'm going to simulate m on w1 to wi
for i steps for each possible i so i'm
going to run m
on
more and more strings for more and more
steps
okay until and every time i notice an m
accepts something i print it out
um
so i will fix this in the uh version of
the uh
file that i
um
publish on the website so if you're
still not getting it you can look there
um
uh but just to make things even worse i
have a check in which is going to
be about this one little point here
so i got a question where do we get the
wi strings the wi strings are simply the
list of all strings in sigma star
so we can under program control
we can
make m
go through every possible string like if
you had an odometer you're going to
first get to the empty string then you
go to the string zero then the string
one you can write a program which is
going to do that
and the turing machine can similarly
write write code to do that
to get to each possible string one by
one and then that's what the
enumerator is doing it's obtaining each
of those strings and then feeding them
into m
seeing what m does
what i'm trying to get at here is that
it's not good to feed them in
run m to completion on each one before
going to the next one you really kind of
have to do them all in parallel
uh
to avoid the problem of getting stuck on
one string that m is looping on
um
all right
so uh this is relevant to your homework
in fact
if i convert m to an enumerator
um
in this way
does that enumerator always print the
strings out in string order
string order is this order here
um
having them uh the having the shorter
strings coming up before the longer
strings and within strings of a certain
length just doing them in lexicographic
order
um
uh so
um
hopefully you follow that but since you
you know these are not
uh correctness that doesn't matter uh
for us let me launch that poll let's
i'll see how confused how random the
answer is here uh
so a fair amount of confusion if you're
confused obviously you're in good
company there um
okay about to shut this down
uh five seconds to go
okay ending in now
uh
all right so the correct answer as the
majority of you did yet is in fact that
the order is not going to be
uh respected here when he
prints things out
it might print out some things later in
the order before earlier things in the
order what's going to control how um
when he is going to print it out it
really is if m
accepts some strings more quickly in
fewer steps
then e might end up printing out that
string earlier in the list
um then some other string that might be
a shorter string
um because
uh the order in which e is go going to
now identify
that m is ex is accepting those strings
is is the um depends upon the speed with
which m is do actually doing the
accepting
so you have to um this is relevant to
one of your homeworks because if
uh what you're going to be asked to show
is that if you start with a decidable
language
instead of a recognizable language
then you can make it then you can make
an enumerator
which always prints out things in order
in the string order
okay
and um
and vice versa so if you have and if you
have a string which uh the numerator
which prints the things out in string
order then the language is it's
decidable
okay so need to think about that
one direction is a fairly simple
modification of what i just showed
the other direction is a little bit more
work um
so uh anyway why don't we uh
uh take our little coffee break here
uh
okay so that's an interesting question
so one question is if there's because
you know sigma has an infinite sigma
star is infinite
um
uh if i understand this question quite
correctly which says you know it's an
infinite number of strings here
uh how how does the machine even get
started because it has to go through and
enumerate all of it no it's not first
writing down all of those strings
um
because yeah you can write down and it
you can't do this infinite step of
writing all the strings what i had in
mind is you're going to take each string
in turn
first you're going to take the first
string on the list of sigma star
run m uh on that string and then the
next string and sigma star run it on
that string and so on string after
string
and so you're never going to have
infinitely many strings to deal with
it's just going to be more and more
strings as you're going along
and um
the question i was trying to get at is
whether you're going to
run each one to complete completion
before you get to the next one or you're
going to kind of try to do them all in
parallel which is what you need to do
for to prove this uh this there
um
won't there be infinitely many wi yes so
there are a similar question infinitely
many wi there are infinitely many wi but
you know it's just an infinite loop that
we're in one by one you're taking care
of
more and more
uh wi as you're going um
uh
let's see here
yes so e is another question is are we
running it all on all the strings in
parallel yes we are running things all
on running all of the strings in
parallel but
you know it's uh running them in
parallel but um these are
um
uh
you know it's we're not defining a
parallel turing machine it's running
them in parallel using time sharing
you know it runs a little bit in this
block runs a little bit and that block
and then another block and sort of
shifts around and sort of does a few
steps of each and that's how it's
getting the effect of the parallelism
um
okay
um
question is
would the enumerator essentially have a
print tape and a work tape yeah you
could think of it as having a print tape
you know however you want to formalize
it it's it it
doesn't matter i mean i'm being a little
whimsical but attaching it to a picture
of a
a real printer but yeah it's just you
think conceptually you can have a print
tape however you like to think about
it's fine um
um
how can we directly say that without
knowing the program of the printer
uh
the printer is just there's no
we don't have to get into the code the
structure of the printer the printer is
just
uh something where you say print a
string and it print and a string comes
out
that's all we know about the printer and
that's all we need to know
um
so there's no program for the printer uh
sorry if i
not understand your question your
question but the question literally says
how can we say that without knowing the
program of the printer
so if the machine is decidable why does
it have to print all strings in order
for example if one string is shorter and
can it be decided later
we well yeah if the
uh the reason why we want
so the question is if the machine is
decidable why does it have to print all
strings in order
uh because that's what i'm asking you to
do in the problem
that's what if you read the problem i
think it's number five
on the pset that's what i'm asking you
to do that's why you have to print it in
order
otherwise you wouldn't have to worry
about printing an order just because i'm
asking you to
okay
so i think we're at a time let's uh
let us move back into um
our our material
um
okay
second half church touring thesis
um
so church uh
this is going back into the bit of the
history of the subject back to the 1930s
um
back then people were uh interested in
formulating the notion of what do we
mean by algorithm they don't even call
it algorithm um and those they they call
it some people call it procedures some
people call it effective procedure
um some people called it
effective calculation um but you know
people had in their minds mathematicians
have been dealing for centuries
thousands of years with procedures for
doing things that's a very natural thing
and
mathematical logicians in particular
church and turing are touring somebody
you
surely obviously have heard of church
maybe not um
a
church was turing's thesis advisor in
fact um and
they both were coming out of the
mathematical logic field of mathematics
and uh using trying to use mathematical
logic to formalize this intuitive notion
of what we have had for for centuries
about what what a procedure is what is
it what is what is an algorithm
and um
back in those days you know they came up
with different ways of formalizing it um
uh so you know here we had this notion
of algorithm which is kind of intuitive
concept
touring proposed turing machine as a way
of capturing that informal way in
mathematically precise way
other people came up with other ways of
doing it
and back then it wasn't obvious that all
of those different formulations would
end up giving you equivalent concepts
equivalent notions um
and in fact they proved in fairly
elaborate detail
that the different methods that people
came up with it was a lambda calculus
there was uh rewriting systems there
were several methods that were proposed
for formalizing um this notion and they
all turned out to be equivalent to one
another
um
in today
that seems kind of obvious
even though i went to some effort to
prove that just to give you a feeling
for how those things uh
go
you know that you know if you have
programs if you have pascal and java say
and thinking about what you can do
mathematically in those i'm not talking
about their ability to interface with
you know windows and so on but just the
mathematical capabilities
the capability of doing mathematical
calculations or functions with a pascal
program or a java program
you know it would be absurd to think
there's some program that you can write
in java that you can't write in pascal
um
or python
and the reason is we know you can
compile python into java and you can
compile java back into python that tells
you that the two systems of two
programming languages are equivalent in
power um that wasn't obvious that from
the get-go to these folks so they um
observed that uh all of the different
efforts they came at formalizing
algorithm all were equivalent to one
another
that was that that was a kind of a
breakthrough moment when they realized
that they're all
that
not all the ways that they've come up
with and once they got the idea they
realized all reasonable ways of doing it
always going to be equivalent
um and so that suggested that
they've really captured this notion of
algorithm by any one of those methods
say a turing machine
and that's what they took you can't
prove that because algorithms are an
intuitive notion
but the fact that we're able to capture
that in a formal way that's what we call
today the church touring thesis
okay um
so um
that is uh
um
so any of these methods uh
capture the notion of algorithm as we
described
and that has had a big impact on
mathematics uh
so you know
i just want to
just give me one second here
all right here's a check-in on this one
so you know alan turing so here are some
facts which may or may not be true about
elementary
um so uh
now you get to pick all the ones that
apply um based on your knowledge
obviously this is not uh
something this is more for fun but um or
historical interest um
but here is uh
let's launch that poll see what how much
you know about
uh mr turing um
check all that apply
okay almost done
please
let's wrap it up
i think that's everybody
okay
two seconds please get credit for doing
this and polling in fact it's kind of
interesting here
uh
um
[Music]
uh he
you all do know that he was a code
breaker uh he was a
worked uh
in fact did was part of a team i think
led the team which broke the german code
um during world war ii
you know the turing test is a famous uh
thing for how do you characterize when
you have an intelligent machine um so he
definitely worked in ai
he worked in biology as well um he has a
paper that less well known to computer
to scientists but if you look him up um
on wikipedia where i get all my
information
uh
uh he actually and i knew this anyway uh
he has a very famous paper influential
paper
on how um
for example spots arise on um on tiger
on leopards and stripes on tigers and so
on um he gave a kind of mathematical
model for that which actually proves
actually is uh quite does capture things
in an accurate way uh as was shown
subsequent to that
uh was imprisoned for being gay in fact
as far as i know from his history he was
not imprisoned for being gay um he was
convicted
of being gay um and he was given a
choice to go to prison or to take
chemicals
to cure
him from being gay
and he opted not to go to prison and
take the chemicals
uh and uh sadly he committed suicide
two years after that
so um he was um
treated very treated very badly by uh
british society and british government
uh despite having the the great the work
that he had done
um
and um
you might think that he has been honored
by appearing on a british banknote
that's also not true um uh but the good
news is he's not uh currently on a
british banknote but he's going to be
on a british bank note starting next
year um
so that is uh
um
so that's uh
you know along with um winston churchill
and a number of other notable brits he's
going to be on the 50 pound banknote
okay um
so let us continue um
so as i mentioned uh the church thesis
is important for mathematics um and it
has to do with these hilbert problems i
don't know how many of you have
encountered that david hilbert was
widely considered to be the
perhaps the greatest mathematician of
his day
um
and um you know every four years
mathematicians get together for an
international congress called the
international congress mathematicians
it was you know email that's been going
on for over 100 years and he was invited
to the 1900
uh meeting to give a talk about anything
he wanted and what he decided to do in
during that presentation is give it is
present 23
uh
problems
that would be a challenge for
mathematicians for the coming century
um and um
uh
you know i we're running a little short
on time so i'm not going to go into them
some of these will talk about later uh
but the tenth problem here is about
algorithms
the tenth problem on hilbert's list
of called called hilbert's tenth problem
is a problem about algorithms and it
says given algorithm for solving what
are called diaphantine equations
um he didn't call it an algorithm you
could call it some uh
you know finite procedure or something
like that
but you know you what are the
diaphantine equations i'm glad you asked
uh
diaphantine equations
uh what are they well they're very
simple they're just polynomial equations
like
you know does this polynomial equal some
constant for example um but where you're
looking for the solutions
you know the polynomials are variables
you're looking for the solutions but
you're only allowing those solutions to
be integers
so here's an example um
so here i give you this polynomial
um here i'm setting it equal to 7
and i want to solve that equation
so it has these three variables x y and
z
so you have to find a solution there but
i'm only going to allow you to have
plug-ins integers and in fact there is a
solution in integers one two and minus
two if you plug it in you'll see it
works
all right uh now the general problem
that hilbert was addressing is suppose i
give you a polynomial
um let's say it said it it's set to zero
so we're looking for roots of the
polynomial but just some polynomial
equation you can always put it in this
form and i want to know
does it have a solution in integers
um and what i want what i'm looking for
is a procedure
which will tell me yes or no i want to
know um
give an algorithm to answer that
question for a given polynomial or using
the language of this course defining
this in terms of a language
uh decide this language give a give a
turing machine which will decide yes or
no for any given polynomial yes there is
a solution in integers no there is no
solution
okay
and um
uh that is a
um uh
um
that was what
um hilbert asked in his tenth problem
given algorithm now as we know now we
took um 70 years to get the answer that
um
that there is no such algorithm it's an
undecidable problem and we'll talk about
that a little bit later in the term but
um there is
d is not a decidable language
now um
there was no hope
of coming up with that answer
in 1900 or even in 1910
because we didn't have a formal idea of
what an algorithm is
that had to wait until the church turing
thesis
told us that algorithms really are
turing machines that there is a formal
way of saying what an algorithm is
and once you had that notion then you
could prove that there is no turing
machine but before that you had only
this vague notion intuitive notion of
what an algorithm is and so there was no
hope of ever answering that because the
in fact the answer is there is no such
algorithm
okay now um i'll give this as a little
exercise to you we're a little bit
running short on time but this language
d is in fact a recognizable language
so i would suggest you think about that
offline um
but basically you know you can try
plugging in different values for these
variables and if you ever find that you
know the um
that it evaluates to zero then you can
accept but otherwise you just have to
keep going and looking so
showing recognizability is very simple
but decidability is false
okay now
let's talk a little bit about encodings
for turing machines um
so
we're going to be working encodings and
turing machines so we're now going to be
working with um
turing machines going forward
we'll go as i you know we're going to
the input to those turing machines might
be polynomials might be strings they
might be other things too we might want
to feed automata
into the turing machines so the turing
machine can answer questions about the
automata
well don't forget turing machines take
as their input just strings
so we have to think about how we're
going to represent
something more complicated like an
automaton as a string
and i'm not going to get into the
details of that you could spell it out
in detail um but i think that's not too
interesting to get into that we're just
going to have develop a notation that
says if you have some object
o
it could be a polynomial it could be an
automaton it could be a graph it could
be whatever you're working with a table
i'm going to write
that o in these brackets
to mean an encoding of that object into
a string
and then you can feed the string into
the turing machine
okay
so that's how we're going to be thinking
of presenting turing machines with more
complicated objects and strings as input
because we're just going to represent
them as strings using some ways in which
i'm sure you're all familiar i mean
that's how you deal with representing
stuff when you're you know how to write
your programs anyway um but just to make
it formal and that's why we're going to
write it down in these brackets and if
you have a list of several objects that
you want to present together
to a turing machine we'll just write
them together within brackets like this
now for writing turing machines down
we're going to going forward we're going
to be using high-level english
descriptions um
we're not going to be worrying about
managing the like the stuff we've been
doing up till now i'm not going to ask
you to do it we're not going to do that
anymore and i'm not going to ask you to
do it managing where stuff goes on the
tapes and all that stuff that's too low
level
because really now that we have the
church turing thesis we're really
interested in talking about algorithms
we're not that interested in talking
about turing machines per se with
ancient algorithms um and what the power
of computation is
so um we're going to only be talking
about touring machines now in a high
higher level way and only when we need
to prove something about uh capabilities
we're going to come back to turing
machines i'm going to be proving things
you know about their limitations and so
on so our notation for running turing
machines is going to be
basically going to put the turing
machine inside these quotation marks and
we're going to know that we could if in
principle write out the touring machine
in a precise way in terms of states and
transition function and so on but we'll
never actually go ahead and do that
lengthy exercise
um so quick check in here
so one of the features well okay let me
not give this away so if x and y are
strings
you know i want to now have a way of
presenting two strings as a single
string as input to my machine because
i always think of my machine as getting
a single input
so would you suggest one way of
combining two strings into one which we
would be a good encoding is just to
concatenate those two strings together
is
would it be that would
would that be the way you would do it is
that a good way to do it or not such a
good way to do it um so let's uh
um
let's see here
i can get to that next
and think what you would want to have
happen
in a good encoding
okay
ready set
sold
uh share results
yeah i think most of you got the idea
that this is not a good way of combining
two strings into one um because
the problem is it's kind of ambiguous in
a sense you know that you could
if you combine two strings this way
what's what's important in an encoding
is that the machine when it gets the
encoding it can decode them back into
the original objects
and if you're just going to be sticking
the two strings together you don't know
where one string
ends and the next string begins
and so it's not going to be a good way
of combining things you you should
find a little bit more clever way of
either introducing another symbol or
it's doing something a little bit more
sophisticated which allow you to be able
to do the decoding as well as the
encoding in a unique way
okay so uh getting back to that notation
for a turing machine so here is the
machine we've already seen once before
for a to the kb to the kc to the k
i would write it now more simply than
managing all of the tapes that we had
the first time around which we did last
lecture i would just say i would give it
an input w
check if w is of the right form with the
things in the right order reject if it's
not
count the number of a's b's and c's and
w
except if all the counts are equal and
reject if not
we're not going to be that's going to be
good enough to be writing things at that
higher level when you're going to be
writing your algorithm descriptions you
just have to make sure that whatever
you're doing you can implement um you
know you you can't make uh you know you
you don't want to be doing tests which
are impossible or doing infinite
infinitely much work in one stage
that's not good um but as long as it's
clear that what you're doing
is doing only a finite amount of work in
every stage and it's something that you
could really implement you can write it
at a high in a high level
um
okay
i wanted to spend a few minutes talking
about problem set two but we a little
bit running out of time here um
uh in particular there was this problem
number five
where you show that a language is turing
recognizable if and only if there's a
decidable d
um
where c is turing recognizable where d
is now a collection of pairs we've got
some questions about the notation which
i hopefully answered now
so um
c
uh
is a set of x's such that there exists a
a string you can pair it with
so that the string x y is in
d um
let me try to give you a picture of that
uh
um
[Music]
so
i'm gonna think of d as a collection of
pairs of strings and it might be helpful
to think of the kind of
you know on the axes here
so if we have a pair of strings x y
which i have not yet packaged into a
single string i'm thinking of them as a
pair of two objects at this moment
uh think of d as so
you know just the x part is just below
here on the x-axis
um d you might want to think just
conceptually we want to think of it as a
collection of pairs
so it's like a subset of all of these
pairs
and
c is all of the
the x's that correspond to any pair in
here
um sometimes we call that the projection
because it's all the things that are
below
or the shadow if you had a light sitting
up here
it's all the things that are kind of
underneath a d um so i've written c here
kind of a little thicker if you can see
that so that's the c language
and um
what you're going to what there's a two
directions here one is a lot easier than
the other if i give you a decidable d
and i want to test whether something's
in c
so i give you an x i want to know is it
is x
in
c
well you now have to test is there some
y that i can pair with x where the pairs
in d
um
so you know you can start looking for
that y if you ever find one
you know that x is in c
there are infinitely many ways to look
for but don't forget
you know
you're only looking for a recognizer for
c
so
you know on the rejecting side you're
allowed to go forever
so i've kind of given you a way to think
about the easy direction the hard
direction
um
you need to think about um
how are you going to come up with that
decidable d if i give you c you have to
find a decidable d and now you're you're
bringing something down lower you're
starting with a recognizing recognizable
language and a decidable language which
is going to sort of be counterpart to
that in this sense is a simpler language
and the way it becomes simpler is that y
is going to help you
determine whether x is in c
um and i guess the thing that you should
i'll leave you with is that maybe we can
talk about this a little bit more on
tuesday i'll try to leave it a little
bit more time
if you want to test if something's in
c x is in c but i don't want to let you
go forever anymore because i want to be
a decidable language
and i'm going to use why to help you
what information would help you
guarantee
you get the right answer for x being in
c
but that you would
have to be sure you're getting the right
answer so it's you know why could just
be the answer but then you know you
don't know that that's you you have to
be convinced that you you have the right
answer you know why just saying what it
is i mean you could well i could say
that x is in d even when it's not true x
isn't c even when that's not true
but so one information would allow you
to check
that
x is in c
what would be helpful information to
check the x's and c
where you would avoid ever having to go
forever
a little bit too rushed here for that to
be helpful anyway let's just uh conclude
what we've done um just brief summary
here
um and i i i don't want to uh
um
keep you going keep you over time so
i'll just leave this up on the board um
i will uh
um
uh
see if there's any so
the lecture is over uh and you can take
off uh as you wish
um i will stick around for a couple of
minutes i have another meeting soon um
but uh i'll answer try to answer some
chats uh
all right um
people are commenting about this movie
about touring the imitation game uh you
know if you haven't seen that i
recommend it um
um and uh
is it a good idea to make y to be equal
to the repeated loop string hmm
i'm not sure about that
uh thank you for the
uh thank you everybody for
sending your kind notes
um
is it
church touring thesis the question is is
it in the book yes it's in the book kind
of similar to what i've already said but
yes
okay this is a good question here
the church turing thesis somebody asked
me is it proved in the book
there's nothing to prove
the church touring thesis
is an equivalence between the intuitive
and the formal
you can't prove something like that
you can just make it's really in a sense
a hypothesis
that the only thing you'll ever be able
to compute
um is something that you can do with a
turing machine
um i mean
that has something to do with the nature
of the physical world and i'm sure i
don't really think that's what people
had in mind it's that you know the the
kinds of things that we normally think
of being able to do with a
with a rest with a procedure
mathematically it's exactly the kinds of
things that you can do with the turing
machine um
so somebody's pointing out well
trying to be helpful here maybe these
folks are asking about equivalence of
various different computation models
being proved in the book not that church
drink these sits itself well
maybe that's
the the things that we proved in lecture
are also proved in the book um about the
equivalence of single tape machines
multitape machines non-deterministic
machines um those are all proved in the
book we don't those i mean there's lots
of models out there so we can spend a
lot of time proving equivalences um and
there are books that do spend a lot of
time proving equivalences but i think
you know
uh
we yeah i i think what we've given is
probably enough um
uh
so somebody that's a good question if if
you give an algorithm
okay if you give an algorithm you don't
need to give the actual machine uh going
forward unless somebody unless you're
explicitly asked to
um
uh but yes you don't you don't have to
give um
the
states and transitions anymore
um
okay so it's a little after four i think
we're going to
i think i'm going to move on to my next
meeting uh so i uh thank you for being
here and i will see you
on tuesday
you